if you're looking to design something
that will get you a paid commission and
actually get you noticed in the
architecture industry
well today i'm going to show you exactly
how to do that
what's going on guys my name's david
thomas welcome back to the channel
today i'm going to show you exactly how
to create something absolutely
stunning it is a very simple
architectural project with a few
very minor details that make it stand
out and look incredible
you guys are more than welcome to use
this for any of your projects any of
your presentations
or use it for whatever you like i just
want to show you exactly how it can be
done in archicad 24. if you like being
part of a community and absolutely love
exclusive content i've created a patreon
link
just down below where you can join my
exclusive
discord chat it is filled with exclusive
content where i talk to you guys
about upcoming architectural projects in
the real world talk about the design
talk about the budget
and the client brief as well we really
try to talk between each other to
improve all these architectural projects
and every so often i jump on there and
help you guys with your projects too
so if that's something interesting
there's a bunch of links down below
check them out
and let's get on with today's video okay
so today i wanted to test out this new
vertical format side by side with the
arc cad video
let me know in the comments down below
what you think of this format versus the
previous format where i'm just a little
floating head down the bottom
i really wanted to engage with you guys
a lot more during this video
so i thought this was potentially the
best way to do it
so i have archicad 24 open in front of
me
i've just opened up the australian
residential template i've done
absolutely nothing to it it is the
standard template you get when you open
up archicad what we're going to do today
is create a unique
cabin chalet and it's going to be
wrapped with the same cladding from the
walls
all the way up with secret gutters i'm
going to show you exactly how to do that
in hopefully
less than 30 minutes once you've got
archicad 24 open
we're going to start straight away by
pressing command and 7 or control
and 7 depending on what system you're on
the ground floor is critical the next
height in this instance is 2 4 7
5 we're going to do it at a timber frame
the first floor is non-existent it's
going to be straight away into the roof
because this is going to be a one-story
design
what we're also going to want to do is
insert something below and
insert our footings which i've
completely spelt wrong so let me try to
spill that properly
our footings need to be 172 millimeters
deep that's approximately the thickness
of the slab that is going to go
underneath
the slab will be 100 plus some
thickenings at the edges
depending on what we go for and if it's
slab on ground but
for the time being we're going 172 we're
also going to untick
all of these on the side so we don't
have anything show up in elevations
later down the track
okay so we can click ok some stories may
be deleted
you will get this error message because
we've deleted that first floor plan
not a problem just click delete anyway
so we want to go into our view map
find sketch design and then go down into
sketch plans
and click on our minus one footings
layer
so this is where we're going to create a
slab and kind of understand
what our building is going to look like
i'm thinking it's going to be a really
nice elongated design
with a protruding element on the front
so maybe some bedroom wings a living
wing
it's just going to be a very simple
chalet design
so in that instance i'm going to grab
the slab tool here make sure it's on our
slab
general layout because we want it to be
on the slab layer layers are very
important when you document later down
the track in archicad
it doesn't matter if it's 24 22 21
archicad layers are critical
we want to go ahead straight away and
change all of these
model override surfaces to black because
we're going to do
a full black design in this instance so
let's go
paint and link all of these together
now at the same time it needs to be
about 100 millimeters thick
and we're going to make it concrete so
if you just tap c it'll quickly jump to
concrete
you don't actually have to look through
this list to find concrete so i quickly
tap c on my keyboard and it would just
jump through the concrete elements
so i've clicked on concrete that's
corrugated roofing let's try again
concrete structural
i've made it 100 millimeters thick and
i've made it project zero
minus 100 so that means it's going to
sit
exactly where the ground floor level
starts let's start
right in the middle of the screen it
doesn't really matter where we start
and start creating our design
i think it'd be nice to have a pretty
elongated design somewhere about that 25
meter mark by about
or six meters could probably do the
trick which will give us decently sized
bedrooms decently sized hallways and
everything in between
so let's go 25 meters by 6
meters long and then on that same
instance what we're going to do is click
control e and then we're going to tap
control again to bring up the multiply
tool
so clicking anywhere in the center we
click once we hold shift to get
a perfectly horizontal line we click
again
rotate around holding shift once more to
get a 90 degree line
and we have our centerpiece so what
we're going to do in this instance
is just drag that and potentially if you
hover over it you're going to see these
two lines pop up
which means i can click control d to
select the center of this line and keep
hovering over this until that secondary
line appears so i know exactly where the
center is of that elongated slab that
i've just created
i don't think this slab needs to be this
far out doesn't need to protrude that
far
so what i'm going to do is click on this
edge just once
and go to offset edges not offset all
edges
just offset edges i'm going to bring it
back in line with the edge of this house
and then i'm going to click control d
and move it to the top
by doing so i've created two spaces
around the house i've created that
elongated shape at the bottom
but now i want to merge that slab
together so i'm going to click on that
original elongated slab
click on one of the corners and make
sure i click add to polygon
the little plus sign with the papers and
then all i'm going to do is hover over
this secondary square
holding space and you're going to notice
this hammer looking tool or magic wand
if you're more familiar with photoshop
that's going to highlight
that entire box so we can just click on
that once and it will automatically fill
that space
so now i can go back in and delete that
additional square that we created before
there's a number of ways to do that step
just there and create multiple slabs
but that one's just a very simple easy
one to do okay so now all we have to do
is jump back to our ground floor plan so
when we build our walls they're on the
right layer
if we double click on ground floor plan
and then right click on our footings
we can go show trace reference layer so
we don't lose our
guidance points if we then come across
to our wall tool in the top left hand
corner
make sure our walls are on walls
external remember again walls and layers
layers are critical in archicad so
continue to keep an eye on your layers
especially if you're working in a team
because it's going to drive people crazy
when it's on the wrong layer
then we're going to select a wall type
in this instance i'm just going to go a
90 mil stud partition
it's not really too important because
this is a theoretical project
and then we're just going to click once
on the corner which is our starting
point
we could go down along the page so it
runs
inside the slab which is the correct way
our timber frame wall would actually go
but then if we go right you'll see it's
on the wrong way around of that slab
so if we just tap the p button on the
keyboard it'll flip that
so if i just keep tapping flip p you'll
see it flipping
i want it to be on the inside of the
slab so the edge of the slab and
the edge of that timber wall are lined
up perfectly
and then all i'm going to do is hold
shift click around
that entire slab that we created before
and just draw an outline of my building
and there we go a few clicks later we
have a full outline of our building
and if we right click anywhere on the
page away from
materials anything that we've built we
can come down all the way to the bottom
and go
show all in 3d you can see there is a
quick command there you can also do
control f5 if you want to
and it will show what we've started
creating in 3d
so now you can see that elongated design
here the black slab we've created at the
bottom
and that is about all we've done so far
what you'll see
is this house is actually floating above
this slab
so one or two things have gone wrong
either this house is too high up
or this slab is too low down and i think
that the slab is too low down
so the quickest and easiest way to fix
that is click on the slab
click on one of the black dots and come
across to the drag tool
then you can just drag it up if you need
to hold shift you can
run it along that parallel line and
click in line with the ground floor plan
so now our slab sits on the edge of our
timber frame walls that don't look like
timber frame walls but
not important because we're going to
clad them with a very unique cladding
material
now we see our general structure we know
what's going on we can come back into
our ground floor plan
if i was doing an internal fit out on
this plan i think this would more than
likely be
the main kitchen living dining space and
then we'd have a master bedroom over
here
with potentially some wet area
facilities a laundry
a bathroom for everybody else and then
there would be
a continuation of two more bedrooms
potentially a master ensuite
and just the spare bedroom as well
potentially even an office so a very
simple
three by two cabin chalet design so
let's say i wanted this first wall
the wrong way up to go from that section
here
to this section here which would create
our
master bedroom or spare bedroom whatever
we wanted there it's a very large
bedroom so
most likely be our master which means we
would need
some sort of ensuite down here then
if we hold the control key and click
once
on this wall it will quickly cut that
entire area out
so now we have our master bedroom and
potentially our ensuite in here
there's a number of ways to extend these
walls across we could hold
alt and activate the eyedropper tool so
we can click on a wall and replicate
those settings
once again clicking p to flip it around
and
doing something like that so we have an
ensuite we could also click on that wall
once
make sure it isn't grouped as a grouped
element
so we can hold alt and g to ungroup
something
so if we hit escape and click on a wall
again you'll see
it's ungrouped but holding alt g again
will quickly regroup that object so you
don't have to worry about
ungrouping objects in theory to actually
ungroup them
and then we'll hold alt again and use
that eyedropper tool to replicate that
interior wall
all the layers are correct so if i click
on an exterior wall you'll see my wall
settings change
and i'll do the same over here so then
again what we're going to do is create
potentially a secondary
bathroom here that could be servicing as
a laundry
or anything in between we'll start
creating our
second bedroom here and
our additional bedroom over here
now we have one bedroom two bedrooms
three bedrooms ensuite
bathroom now what we could do as well is
extend this little wall across in line
with that
giving its own little private hallway so
then we could enter into here into a
small little powder room
or if we wanted to we click control
again and delete that wall in the center
so we have
a passage a door into our master bedroom
an ensuite
secondary bedroom an office whatever we
wanted
and then it would be a bit of an
elongated hallway but there'd be no
views at the back so we wouldn't have to
worry about it
and this would be our kitchen living and
dining spaces
overall we have about nine and a half
meters there so that's
relatively small for a kitchen living
dining but it would most likely be one
main kitchenette along the back
with your main entry coming through some
sort of deck of alfresco
and then we would also have our main
dining and living spaces in here
so now we have some interior floor plan
guide that we can continue building upon
so if we click on our door tool we can
come into our door 24 objects we can see
arccat has a number of different doors
available for us to use
if i just click on this first door and
then click override
pen objects and change that orange to
black because it looks
horrible i can then click on hinge door
settings at the top and
go through all of these settings to
change what this
door would look like if you need a front
view you can click on that front item
come through all these settings change
them exactly how we like for interior
door
you can have all sorts of different
patterns and styles we'll just click on
that one for
the point of argument change the handle
let's go
some nice handle with a lock
and it puts it on directly there so
now we can come back in and start
putting in doors into our design
so we have a couple doors here we have a
door into our ensuite
we have a door into our study here we
have a door into our master bedroom
we need our external doors our windows
and
everything else so if we go back into 3d
we can start seeing that we've created
all those internal walls we've modeled
those doors
and if you don't know how i'm flying
around like this by holding shift and
the middle
scroll wheel clicking it down you can
orbit around
the actual project you can also click
this little explore man down the bottom
and play it like a video game
wsd moving around looking around with
your mouse
and then escape gets you out of that
mode we see that we understand our
internals we have our externals and we
can continue modeling
so if we come back into ground floor
plan we can actually go into our window
tool
click on the window and open up the
settings you can also get into this by
clicking command t
and let's just search for a sliding door
now there are a number of sliding doors
we can use
archicad has hundreds and hundreds of
them for this
let's just go with a typical four sash
sliding door i don't like the fact that
it has this upper sash so all we're
going to do is click
left here on the shape and go none
so that completely removes that shape
there what i also want to do is make
that door to 400 high
because is it definitely not tall enough
for 1500 for a person to get through and
drop the seal height to zero so it's
flat on the ground
same thing we did with doors coming into
floor plan and section
settings over clicking the overripe pen
objects and changing it from orange to
black because it
drives me crazy now i like to see
opening lines on my windows so i know
where i'm actually going and what the
doors are doing so if we click on
this drop down menu and come down to
opening lines we can go
over right model view options and get
our opening symbols
on this door which is great so now we
can just quickly click ok
and start dropping in a couple doors
where we think we're going to need them
so obviously this has multiple entries
multiple exits
we're going to use all three here i'm
thinking we're going to have a decked
area here
a decked area over here and then
potentially 180 degrees from this side
and multiple accesses
from that master ensuite this is a
little bit narrow in my personal opinion
i'd probably make it anywhere from about
three and a half to four meters
so in this instance i'll stretch that
out four meters
what i'll do with this one edge and drag
it
all the way across do the same drag it
all the way across
so now we have roughly a 4 2 sliding
door
do the same on this side do the same on
that side that's a 5 meter sliding panel
door
which is probably a little bit too large
but it can still be done clicking back
into a 3d
we can see we've started to create our
glass elements for our house
if we jump down to footings we're going
to go back into our footings layout
where we created our slab
i want to hold the alt key and
activate my eyedropper tool on top of
this slab
and then i'm going to jump to the
geometric rectangular method
shape click on the corner and snap onto
this edge
i want to make that about four meters
wide and then i'm going to go into the
settings by clicking command or control
t
and changing that to some sort of timber
we're going to select the timber floor
down here just to change the structural
composition it's going to be a bit
thicker than that let's go 190 for the
purpose of this and then
clicking okay by clicking control d and
then
tapping control again i can easily
replicate that to the other side
without having to do too much we're
going to go back into our window tool
go back to our settings dialog box
change that to just
straight up window now we typed in
window i'm going to actually just
continue to type in window 24
because i know the window i want
specifically that is the window i want
to use in this instance
so if we come back to the top go all the
way back up to start of this menu and
work our way through
i want to make this some sort of an
awning window so it's probably going to
be about
750 wide and potentially
800 high it could be more it could be
less depending on the window
manufacturers in your country and
how much glass you can actually put in a
single pane so if we come into this main
sash setting in the opening type we can
change
side hung to top hung which top hung
means it's going to pivot from these
points here and it's going to be fixed
at the top of the window
and you're going to be able to open it
from that bottom point there if we
wanted to get creative we go in and do
handles and all sorts of different bits
and pieces but we're not going to worry
about any of that we're just going to
click
ok and then i'm going to drop in two of
these
awning windows right here i want to do
the same by clicking alt
and just dropping in two more of these
windows over here for some ventilation
and one long skinny window here so i can
use
that window as it is and then click on
it again
open up the settings to change what we
have by clicking on this list i can come
back to the opening settings and just
changing that to a fixed glass panel
i only want this to be about 700
millimeters high
but i do want it to be very very long i
don't know how long it's going to be in
this instance so
i'm just going to use the drag or move
node tool here
to make it as long as i need it to be
now if i click that it has a seal of
zero i'm going to move that up to 900
because that would be my bench height
which probably means these windows here
also have a seal of zero
i don't want these windows to have a
seal of zero so i'm just going to hold
shift as i click through to select them
all at once and change all their
settings at once
i want them to have a seal of about 600
i think in this
instance will look really really good we
can probably replicate
this window again once more here and
once more on that side there to give
that space some sort of natural
ventilation if we go back into our show
3d we can see
that we have all of this modeled all of
our house is starting to come together
we have this giant pane of glass
that is probably going to be a bit too
expensive for this project so if we
click control
or command and t we'll open up the
dialog settings again
and what we want to do is find the
setting that allows
us to put a transom in the middle so
number of ways to do it i find the
easiest way to do it is to come back to
sash type
no grid hv grid vertical one
horizontal and that way we've created
that center break in the glass we can
make that
50 millimeters thick and thickness 50
millimeters
so it's actually a solid piece of
framework aluminium
timber whatever the frame you're going
with and that makes that window
significantly cheaper to create than
having one giant pane of glass
now what we're going to do is continue
with our cladding of
the external side so if we go back into
our ground floor plan
and select all of our external walls
so now there's a number of ways you can
do this you can go in and get the
graphisoft accessories pack which is
completely free i believe for most
graphisoft users
but personally i use ci tools because i
find it
a much more comprehensive package it's
an extra couple hundred bucks a year
for the archicad software but i think
it's a definitely a worthwhile plug-in
to get
so if we go to our coverings in ci tools
and
go to wall coverings we can see our wall
coverings panel
open up if i go back to the start
of all the settings and work my way
through it we're going to see
all sorts of different settings we want
to move to the covering
section and these are the settings that
you want to use
you want to go ribbed if i flip that
around 180
we can see that it's going vertically
and these are the settings you want to
use to get this max line look we're
talking about today
we want to go through these settings
here so take a screenshot do whatever
you need to do pause the video
make sure you get those settings
identical make sure your cladding
orientation is
90 degrees and then all we're going to
do is go surface override
click on that and change it to some sort
of black
color all we want to do and then we
click ok
and you'll see it starts creating this
offset
of that wall we want to drag our mouse
to the outside of the wall because
that's where we want our cladding to go
so we just click on the outside and it
will automatically create our cladding
now if i go back to our 3d this is where
it gets really cool
so now we have this extremely nice
black ribbed metal cladding
that is an extremely expensive finish
look
but it is an incredible product at the
end of the day
so it's starting to look a lot better
and it's starting to look
really unique and architectural so now
what i notice is all my window frames
are the wrong color and it just doesn't
work with a design
so if we click on one window click ctrl
f
to open up our find and select then we
can click our
copy settings for that window i'm
looking to replace
all the windows i don't want to go in
and create different criteria just click
the select item and it will select
all our windows in the project click
ctrl t
command t whatever system you're on open
up the window 24
settings and go to the settings where we
change our model
attributes all we want to do is scroll
down and change that to the same black
color you selected before
so clicking through all of them
individually black black black now all
our window frames have changed to black
and we have a much better much
cleaner look so overall our design
started to come together
but obviously if we left it like this it
would rain it would get destroyed we
need some sort of roof structure
so if we come across to our roof plan at
the top
double click that and then we're going
to right click
and show as trace reference on our
ground floor plan
so we know exactly where our walls are
we come across to our roof tool
and in this instance i'm going to use
the multi-plane
geometry and then split it break it
apart to do what i want to do
so if we zoom in to one of our walls
we're just going to trace around all our
walls so now i've traced around all the
walls going on
that exterior edge and clicking on the
final bit
what i want to do is click again on that
roof structure
you can see it's created this overall
roof shell
this is the roof we've created that
looks very basic it looks like your
generic average house
so we're going to go back into our roof
we're going to change our overhang
to zero we don't want to overhang on
this and we want a much
higher pitch so let's go 30 degrees for
now
and see how that works so if we click
enter come back into our 3d model
we can see that's already started to
change
so now this is still looking very basic
if we come back into our roof structure
right click on our roof and then go
split into single pane rooves and then
go split anyway don't worry about that
warning it's just telling you
it's going to be a mess we have to
ungroup our roof by clicking alt
g which gives us the ability to click on
one roof plane instead of
all of them at once so alt and g we can
click on one if alt g
isn't selected you have all of them so
we're going to delete that roof
we're going to delete that roof and
we're going to delete that section of
the roof
now what we're going to do is click on
that panel of the roof
click on the end node and drag it in
line
with the edge we'll do the exact same
for that side
and the same for these two rubs over
here now it's critical that this node
aligns with this node otherwise
when we start doing our roofing
materials it won't line up and you're
going to have some problems
so so now all we have to do is go back
into our 3d layout and you're going to
see that roof has changed all of a
sudden we're starting to get that cabin
look it's starting to look a lot cooler
a lot nicer but i still think the roof
pitch is a little low
so i'm going to click on one go alt g
open up my settings
and change that pitch to about 35
degrees
now we have a very steep pitch roof and
it's starting to look quite nice
i'm going to ungroup all these walls
select
that wall this wall and this last wall
over here
that are all at the ends of these gable
roofs
click on the edge go to my stretch
height
tool and stretch it just past the tip of
that roof
it's going to do absolutely nothing at
the start but that's okay we still have
all three of those walls highlighted
so we're going to right click anywhere
in the project while everything's still
highlighted go to connect
go to solid element operations and then
we're going to click on our roof
quickly clicking alt g to select all of
them we're going to add that as our
operator
change the subtract with an upwards
extrusion and
click execute now nothing's changed
again for a very simple reason because
our cladding protrudes
past our wall edge and our roof does not
so so now what we want to do to make
sure we can crop this roof here is go
back into our roof plan
and offset all of these edges 110 mil so
we simply do that by clicking on any of
the roofs
clicking on the edge line and going
through
one by one and extending it 110 mil
so now i've completed the offset of all
edges if i go back into 3d we'll see
we've
cropped that cladding perfectly
with the roof line so now we're going to
jump back into our roof
click on the roof select all the roof
shadings
go back into our ci tools coverings and
go roof coverings this time
so the same way we wrote down all those
settings for the max line cladding
around the walls we're going to come
back into our roof go
ribbed and we're going to change these
settings
to match the other settings okay the one
thing you have to be careful of
is the simple fact that in the roof and
the wall claddings
these are in different orders so if you
want to screenshot this again
or pause this video to get these
settings correct in this order for the
roof sheeting
go ahead get it right okay so now if we
click ok we've seen that we've
replicated that cladding
and it lines up with the edge of our
roof
what it doesn't do though is our roof
sheeting doesn't go all the way up to
the edge
because we've extended it that little
bit too far
but first of all we're going to change
these gutters so we can
actually connect those wall and roof
detail together so what we do is we open
up
the settings of the roof we go into the
cladding
jump all the way down to gutters and
change our quarter round
to our parapet so a parapet will create
an internal gutter it'll probably be
quite
deep because it's quite small so let's
go 180 gutter for the purpose of this
and click ok now you'll see that that
gutter has been
created now we need this roof to sit
higher up because that gutter isn't
working
so if we open up our settings for the
roof go to our framing options
and change 45 to maybe 90 in this
instance
we can see that gutter goes all the way
past
now which is exactly what we're trying
to achieve all we have to do now is come
back into our roof settings
open up our layers by going control l
and
taking off this roof cover the roof
cover is now dedicated onto archicad
layer
we're just going to change it to
something a bit different so we'll call
it shell
general for now and if we go ctrl
l move down to shell general turn that
off
go okay that disappears and we no longer
have our roof
shell activated if i click on our roof
overall i can go back in and subtract
110 mil
from what i originally added previously
on these sides
so we don't need it on the sides we only
need it on the edges
where the front of the building meets
the new gable ends that we created
before
so we only need a 110mm offset here 110
there and 110 there
now if i go back in to my 3d view
we're going to see all these errors
coming up because we're not cropping in
line with that roof anymore but that's
okay we're going to deal with that in a
minute we're going to come across and
select one of these walls internally
here
what i want to do is align this to the
edge so if i find this internal wall
here i can find
out exactly how tall that wall needs to
be
for this to look like it's aligning so
from a distance
it won't align perfectly because the
timber roof doesn't allow that so we're
going to
extend that wall just to about
here and then what we're also going to
do is click on that roof covering
and extend the roof covering 35
millimeters
just on one side which is our framing
structure
so now you can see we've created that
secret gutter
that comes down on the edge of this side
of the building
and we just need to get rid of that
section of the wall
now if these corners do occur to you
there is a very simple way to get rid of
them
we can go ctrl l and hide our roof shell
to be able to do this properly so we
just hide our roof shell there
we're gonna click on that covering click
on those two
roof sections there right click connect
trim to roof element and click ok
and they're gone we're gonna do the same
on this side
one two right click connect trim
okay gone run around this side
click one two right click connect
trim gone there we go we can turn on
our roof right now and we can see
our almost finished product looking
absolutely incredible so now we have
this
modern country barn that is wrapped with
this
unique black metal cladding
and it lines up with these secret
gutters
as well that's pretty much it guys
there's nothing more to it we've created
a unique
cabin that has some concealed gutters it
has the unique metal cladding wrapping
all the way around
it has all those window and door
penetrations
and it is a unique cabin that you can
use for your portfolio for your projects
whatever you want to do
we would then usually take this into
twin motion to create an even better
render of this
but we're not going to showcase that in
this video today if that's something
you're interested in make sure you
subscribe i do make those videos from
time to time
but that's all we have time for today
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
if you did make sure you smash that
subscribe button just down there
and don't forget about that like button
the like button helps this video with
the youtube algorithm and it makes sure
more and more people can see videos like
this and we can continue
growing this community anyway that's all
from me so like always i will see you
next monday